das stellt wirklich alles auf dem kopf
künstliche intelligenz ki übernimmt
menschliche aufgaben denn diese ki ist
in der lage mathematische vermutung und
theoreme aufzustellen bislang galt das
als völlig undenkbar und den menschen
vorbehalten ein lernfähiger algorithmus
bringt so also die mathematische
grundlagen forschung einen großen
schritt nach vorne wie kann das sein
verändert dass unsere sicht auf die
möglichkeiten der ki klicks und ganz der
future bis dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen das ist wirklich
eine spektakuläre premiere und in meinem
buch per aufzug in den weltraum habe ich
genau das vorhergesagt riesige
fortschritte bei der ki der link ist
hier unter me und diese aktuelle
premiere wirft neue fragen auf ist
künstliche intelligenz den menschen bald
schon ebenbürtig denn mal klar helfen
computer und künstliche intelligenzen
bereits heute beim berechnen und der
analyse gigantische zahlen mengen doch
in der grundlagenforschung der
mathematik hat man sich noch nicht so
wirklich mit einem ki system
herangetraut denn bislang war das eine
sache die tatsächlich nur menschen
vollbringen das aufstellen neuer
vermutungen und theorie mit der
mathematik etwas das vor allem mit der
menschlichen intuition verknüpft worden
denn das erkennen von zusammenhängen und
mustern die bisher unbekannt waren kann
nicht programmiert werden so die annahme
bis jetzt die rede ist in diesem
zusammenhang immer von der hohen kunst
der intuitiven mathematik war sie
unerlaubt vor maschinen falsch gedacht
das beweist jetzt ein ki system in
dietmanns neuester forschung gibt meint
ist die google-tochter für künstliche
intelligenz und hat bisher mit alpha und
alfred evers menschen um längen
geschlagen alpha ist der beste
golfspieler der welt und als erfolg an
proteine falten hoch komplexe moleküle
mit einer bis dahin nicht für möglich
gehaltenen erfolgsquote und jetzt die
fachleute von die mine konnten mit der
hilfe von künstlicher intelligenz
tatsächlich eine neue vermutung in der
algebra offenbaren und zudem ein neues
theorem der knoten theorie dazu ist
jetzt eine aktuelle studie im
renommierten fachmagazin nature
veröffentlicht worden also was kann das
ki system wirklich können uns künstliche
intelligenzen also selbst in buch
komplexen um abstrakten fachgebieten wie
der theoretischen mathematik wertvolle
hilfe leisten werden ki systeme fleisch
schon bald wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler also menschen komplett
ersetzen die antworten auf all diese
fragen und alle weiteren infos über den
neuen erfolg von dittmann gibt es jetzt
hier bei klick zum science im schuljahr
das britische unternehmen und außerdem
auch google tochter dieb meint sorgt
immer wieder für spannende schlagzeilen
vor vier jahren der erste beweis dass
die meint in sachen ki ganz weit vorne
ist das programm alpha zero hat sie sich
innerhalb weniger stunden selbst
beigebracht schach zu spielen danach
dann das duell gegen das freie
schachprogramm stockfisch das bis dahin
als unangefochten im computer schach
galt schnell stand fest dass stockfisch
keine chance hatte der englische
schachmeister daniel king hatte die
beiden kontrahenten damals ganz genau im
visier bei seiner analyse umschrieb er
das spiel von alpha sieger mit begriffen
die charakteristisch für menschliches
verhalten sind die mein ski hatte
demnach zitat langfristige pläne und
position elle vorlieben absolut mein
block im jahr 2020 war dann von einem
echten durchbruch die rede die meint
hatte als verfault entwickelt eine
künstliche intelligenz die in der lage
dazu ist etwas voraus zu sagen was die
fachwelt trotz jahrzehntelanger
forschung noch immer nicht schafft die
algorithmen sagen voraus wie sich ein
protein genau falten wird und dafür
müssen sie einzig und allein den mix aus
aminosäuren kennen aus denen die
proteine bestehen und an dieser stelle
muss man echt mal festhalten das ist vor
allem für die mikrobiologin
mikrobiologen dieser welt ein echter
durchbruch ja so etwas wie der heilige
gral der mikrobiologie aber nicht nur
die grundlagenforschung wird durch
dieses ergebnis profitieren sondern auch
die pharmazeutische und medizinische
forschung
gleich mehrere meldungen aus dem gibt
meint kosmos sorgen in diesen tagen für
spannung demnach hat das künstliche
neuronale netz gibt main 21
ein physikalisches problem gelöst an dem
sich wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler bereits seit jahren die
zähne ausbeißen konkret geht es hierbei
um die sogenannte dichte funktional
theorie dft für die ein österreichischer
physiker im jahr 1998 den chemie
nobelpreis erhielt dazu der leiter des
team meint 21 forschungsteams james
kirkpatrick die dfc beschreibt im
wesentlichen wie sich die energie in
einem molekül durch die wechselwirkung
von elektronen verteilt sie war extrem
erfolgreich wird von vielen chemiker und
materialwissenschaftler
verwende doch trotz ihres erfolges und
ihrer popularität hat die theorie einige
schwerwiegende defekte fehler gibt es
vor allem in den bereichen in denen die
physik in die chemie übergeht doch dann
brachte das forschungsteam das
künstliche neuronale netz die meint 21
ins spiel die selbstlernende software
wurde mit den daten von mehr als 2000
chemischen reaktionen gefüttert die ki
entwickelte auf dieser grundlage eine
neue variante der dfg und die burg
gleich zwei vorteile zum einen werden
absurde rechenergebnisse vermieden und
zudem sind ihre beschreibungen präziser
als die bisherigen beschreibung wahnsinn
man kann gar nicht sagen wie absolut
baden brechen dieser fortschritt ist in
meinem buch darauf zu den weltraum ich
habe es ja schon erwähnt hatte ich ja
solche risiken fortschritte im bereich
der ki vorhergesagt der link zum buch
ist immer noch ihr untermieter und darin
gibt es noch mehr solcher vorhersagen
die mit an sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit eintreten werden
quantencomputer raumfahrt und noch viel
mehr gibt es zu einer weiteren wirklich
spannenden meldungen aus dem bereich der
mathematischen grundlagen forschung und
dies meist gleich alle annahmen die man
bisher über den einsatz von crm systemen
in hochkomplexen abstrakten fachgebieten
hatte
den haufen denn bisher war man fest
davon ausgegangen dass ki system nicht
in der lage sind in der mathematischen
grundlagen forschung weiter zu helfen
das aufstellen von mathematischen
vermutungen und theorien war bislang nur
uns menschen zugetraut worden dazu sagt
der dickmann forscher alex davies
funktion eines mathematikers spielt eine
enorm wichtige rolle für mathematische
entdeckung doch das britische
unternehmen hat es sich nicht nehmen
lassen auch diese herausforderung
anzunehmen als inspiration für ihre
entwicklung hatten die forschenden den
indischen mathematiker srinivasan rahman
julian im kopf er hatte sich alle seine
mathematischen kenntnisse autodidaktisch
aus der fachliteratur beigebracht vor
allem hatte er ein besonderes talent
dafür zahlen theoretische und
analytische probleme zu lösen und muster
zu erkennen und zwar mit hilfe seiner
intuition meistens also konnte er für
seine lösung nicht mal beweise oder den
lösungsweg angeben ein mathematisches
genie also keine frage er ist also
möglich solch eine begabung auch einer
künstlichen intelligenz beizubringen die
dann in der lage wäre um bekannte muster
in daten aufzudecken und tatsächlich
gibt meint ist es gelungen ein system zu
entwickeln das zum ersten mal überhaupt
mathematische verknüpfung aufgedeckt hat
die mathematikerinnen und mathematikern
bislang verborgen blieben für dieses
projekt hatte sich das britische
unternehmen drei mathematiker mit ins
boot geholt das ziel das lösen von zwei
mathematischen problemen eines in der
theorie der symmetrie und eines in der
knoten theorien in diesen beiden
themengebieten sollten mathematisch
hypothesen dann von den neu entwickelten
ki system überprüft werden dabei könnten
dann neue vermutungen oder theorie
entwickelt werden dazu sagt der
australische wissenschaftler andreas
juhra
lernfähige maschinen können interessante
und beweisbare vermutung in gebieten
aufdecken in denen es zu viele daten
oder zur umfangreiche objekt gibt um sie
mit klassischen methoden zu erforschen
unsere hypothese war dass es eine noch
unentdeckte beziehung zwischen den über
modische und algebraischen in varianten
1 knoten gibt das war also die erste
frage die das ker-system klären sollte
konkret wurde die ki also darauf
trainiert geometrische in varianten zu
überprüfen damit gemeint sind
mathematische eigenschaften die einen
knoten beschreiben und von anderen
abgrenzen
die analyse sollte klären ob es mögliche
querverbindungen gibt und tatsächlich
vermeldete denn die meint algorithmus
einen erfolg denn er fand drei in
varianten die eine verbindung der
algebraischen signatur des knotens und
der geometrischen beschreibung seiner
steigung offenbar der rest der schaden
im teamwork mit dem menschlichen
mathematikern auf grundlage der neuen
entdeckung konnten die wissenschaftler
dann nämlich nicht nur eine neue
vermutung ableiten sondern sogar direkt
beweisen eine absolut echte premiere
dazu heißt es in der aktuellen studie
diese theorie ist eines der ersten das
algebraische und geometrische in
varianten von coach verknüpft dies hat
vielfache interessante an denn
tatsächlich ist die knoten theorie in
einigen fachbereichen sehr spannend so
zum beispiel in der chemie und biologie
wenn es um dna stränge geht oder auch in
der astrophysik nämlich beim
wechselspiel von verschiedenen kräften
in der sonnenkorona diese erkenntnis hat
sogar die fachleute selbst verwundert es
ist überraschend dass eine so einfache
und dennoch profunde verknüpfung bisher
übersehen wurde und das in einem gebiet
das intensiv erforscht worden auch im
zweiten einsatzgebiet konnte das ki
system überzeugen hier ging es um die
darstellung theorie mit am start war der
australische mathematiker john dee
williams um vermutung in meinem
fachgebiet aufzustellen oder zu beweisen
manchmal unendliche räume und extrem
komplexe gleichung sätze über multiple
dimensionen hinweg nötig es geht hierbei
also um die lineare algebra und eine
bestimmte art elemente und gruppen über
symmetrien im hör dimensionalen raum
abzubilden und zu beschreiben und
tatsächlich das neue ki system wurde
selbst zum mathematiker mit ihrer hilfe
gelang sven janssen eine seit 40 jahren
unvollendete vermutung zu vollenden das
so das forschungsteam dies ist das erste
mal dass eine kuh ihre nützlichkeit für
einen rein theoretischen mathematiker
für mich gewesen hat die intuition kann
zwar weit bringen aber die kann uns
dabei helfen verbindungen zu finden die
für den menschlichen geist nicht immer
leicht zu erkennen sind beide erfolge in
der mathematischen grundlagen forschung
beweisen dass ki systeme mittlerweile so
weit entwickelt sind dass sie in
zahlreichen fachgebieten wertvolle hilfe
leisten können sogar in abstrakten und
hochkomplexen fachgebieten wieder rein
mathematik das maschinelle aufspüren von
mustern und das aufstellen von
mathematischen vermutungen könnte also
schon bald zur normalität werden und wir
noch mehr interesse an der zukunft hat
mein buch per aufzug in den weltraum
beschreibe ich ganz konkret was schon in
naher zukunft realität wird was heute
noch wie eine utopie wirkt und das ist
zum teil schon ziemlich verblüffend das
buch gibt es hier einfach draufklicken
oder mit dem link in der video
beschreibung oder im ersten angebunden
kommentar bis dann bleibt dran